It's time for Drew's News,
your good news flashlight in the middle of the night.
I personally like a headlamp, hands free.
And with me at the desk,
the best co-pilot in the business, Rossy Ross Matthews.
Yes! Hi, everybody!
(audience cheering excitedly)
Hi, hi.
I love you in an olive!
This is the first time I've worn this jacket.
You like?
I love.
I got it at the mall myself,
I did, cute.
(audience laughing warmly)
And the collar on your shirt, very unique.
Yeah, I took a risk.
And you, I heard you said
you were doing a Diane Chambers look,
is that what you said?
No, but they were playing "Cheers" backstage.
Oh, they were.
I'm binging "Cheers" on Hulu right now on the train,
and it's like, some of her looks totally remind me of you.
You could pull any sort of bloused sleeve-
I love a Diane Chambers reference, I will take it.
You are welcome for that!
Thank you, Shelley Long!
And we are sort of the Sam and Diana daytime,
will we won't we, you know what I mean?
(Ross and Drew laughing amusingly)
Usually, I'm hawking the idea to you
and you're like, "What are you talking about?"
I'm like, "Girl, wrong tree you're barking.
Let's move on."
(audience laughing warmly)
I know, it's my life pattern to bark up the wrong tree.
I know you're not interested in me, Rossy.
I'm interested you in every way, but one.
And that's why this works.
Exactly. Cheers to you.
And I am the flower girl at your wedding.
Yes, you are!
Alright, well before we hit the headlines, we have a PSA
for anyone who's about to take their passport photo.
Yup.
How do I know this?
Well, I just tried to upload my new passport photo
and I got a message that said my photo was rejected.
And the reason why was a smile was detected.
Look at her. (Ross laughing amusingly)
I look too happy!
You do!
They rejected my photo!
(Ross laughing amusingly)
And here is my fully approved passport photo.
Can you believe this?
Does anyone know that you are not allowed to smile
in a passport photo?
Raise of hands, who knows this?
Oh, everybody.
(audience laughing amusingly)
Well in your defense,
I only know this 'cause they told me "stop smiling"
when I got the picture taken.
Why is this?
Hello, we're literally going into other countries,
we don't wanna do it smiling?
Like, I'm friendly, hello!
But like, what's the difference?
It's still me.
Cute!
Me.
(audience laughing amusingly)
Well okay, so everybody now knows no smile!
Welcome to the country.
(Ross laughing amusingly)
(audience applauding)
Alright, well-
That's hilarious, Drew.
This story is very meaningful.
Everyone is tuning into Amy Poehler's
directorial intimate portrait of Lucille Ball
and Desi Arnaz, called "Lucy and Desi."
The New York Times reports that the new Amazon documentary
tells the story of the couple in their own words.
Amy went through hours of audio tapes
to reconstruct their incredible story.
Now, if you've seen the movie that's out,
obviously right now, this is a completely different take.
Take a look.
"I Love Lucy" built every episode
around that idea of fracture and come back together.
And I think we crave that as humans.
No matter what you've done, I forgive you.
(audience laughing relatably)
♪ Will you still love me ♪
You don't necessarily have to be a funny person
to get a laugh.
♪ Beautiful ♪
I'm not a funny person.
♪ Will you still love me? ♪
The show was one of the most wonderful things
that happened in my life.
We brought the rafters down.
(audience laughing)
♪ I know you will ♪
♪ I know that you will ♪
At the core, it's all about unconditional love.
(audience cheering happily)
I know, it's so good.
Oh my God.
It's hardcore, but I've been watching it
and it is so detailed and it goes...
You think you know the story,
and Amy shows us it's so much deeper in their own words.
It's so intimate.
It's so well done.
Amy said that she wanted to expand our definition
of what a successful partnership looks like.
Oh God.
And Lucy and Desi got divorced, but they co-parented
and remained loving and respectful partners until the end.
(sighing deeply) This really strikes a chord.
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
It really does.
I just found this whole project fascinating.
I can't recommend it enough.
On Amazon right now.
Good job, Amy.
(uplifting music)